welcome and thanks for joining me on
this let's call it a voyage of the mind
so before we begin
posture and breathing make a big
difference in meditation
so if you're not already on a nice firm
chair with your back straight
pause this recording and go find a nice
firm chair with your back straight
ideally in a place that's kind of quiet
and peaceful
so now that you're there
sit with your back straight
try to put your feet firmly on the floor
when i do this i like to rest my hands
on my lap palms up gently curled so
really no effort
and now
start
to slowly breathe a bit deeper than you
were just now and a bit slower
in
and out at your own time but just a
little bit deeper
a little bit slower
if you like
a lot of folks like to breathe in
through their nose
out through their mouth
but the key once again
a little bit deeper a little bit slower
and as you do so
start to soften your gaze if your eyes
are still open
and when you feel comfortable
gently close your eyes
now before we get into the heart of the
meditation i'm going to give you a few
reminders
this whole exercise
is about exploring
your inner being it's about curiosity
it's about relaxation there's no perfect
way to meditate
sometimes folks think that they're not
doing it right or their mind is
wandering too much and then it causes
stress and that's the exact opposite of
what you want meditation to be it should
be fun it could even be funny at moments
you should be curious you should be
enjoying it
if there are some random distractions
and there inevitably will be it could be
sounds around you it might be part of
your body that itches or tingles
don't let it stress you out
just accept it it's part of the universe
it's just atoms doing what they do it's
the universe doing its thing and no
worries if you need to scratch or adjust
part of your body
no reason to stress
now to add to the idea that this
shouldn't be a stressful experience i'm
going to ask you to do something that
may or may not feel completely natural
i want you to smile right now give
yourself a good smile with your eyes
closed just smile
obviously we smile when we're happy but
sometimes
making a smile can actually make us a
little bit happier it can make us a
little bit less stressed
so even if you need to force it smile
and as much as possible as we go through
this meditation as long as you don't
have to force it too much try to keep a
gentle smile on your face the whole time
all right now let's get into it
so
one thing to keep in mind as we start
trying to still our minds
is to just appreciate
that you're alive
you're in this vast mystery we call life
and that you're taking pause to
appreciate who you really are
and the beauty of this mystery this
existence this universe that we share
so as you breathe
deeper
and slower
your eyes are closed
try to become aware of your thoughts
what are you thinking about
are they random thoughts
something you saw on tv is it something
going on at school
are you thinking about
some test you might have coming up
or someone at your school you tend to
think about a lot
just observe your thoughts don't try to
fight them just observe them
and as you observe your thoughts
start to appreciate that
you are not your thoughts
you are something different than your
thoughts
they're all in there in your head with
you but clearly you can observe them you
can see them go by
sometimes we can get lost in them
but i think you're seeing right now that
you are not your thoughts you can
actually observe your thoughts
one metaphor that folks sometimes use is
that your thoughts are cars on a road or
cars on a highway and oftentimes we're
in the middle of the highway and those
cars are bombarding us they're hitting
us or we have to dodge them in some way
or they're overwhelming us
and one thing to do to observe them is
just get out of the highway you don't
have to fight the thoughts those cars
will keep on going by
but now that you're on the median you're
no longer on the highway you can see
them go by
and what you'll often find is when
you're observing your thoughts they
start to slow down
and so if your thoughts start to slow
down great
really embrace that start to realize
what that feels like when your thoughts
slow down
and then there's even going to be
moments when you have no thoughts
for the next few breaths try that
try to have no thoughts
just breathe in
breathe out
no thoughts
just stillness
just your consciousness here in this
universe
no time
no space
it's all in your mind
no thoughts stillness
now as you try to keep that state your
mind will inevitably wander
you're going to start thinking about an
assignment that you have due soon you're
going to think about
something that you have to do this
weekend or
someone that you that you think a lot
about
that's okay
don't beat yourself up if your mind
wanders just remind yourself just gently
nudge it back try to get back to the
stillness say oh look i i got a little
bit distracted i started thinking about
something that's funny i'm going to get
my mind back to the stillness i'm going
to try to slow down those cars
and so gently breathe in and breathe out
and i'm going to give you a few minutes
to just sit there
still
breathing in
breathing out
being still with your thoughts if your
mind wanders
no big deal
just try to nudge it back when you can
and if the silence starts to get to you
a little bit don't worry i will be back
for sure in a few minutes
now that you've had a little bit of time
on your own i'm gonna give you some
ideas that just might help appreciate
who you really are
a lot of times we get caught up in the
day-to-day
we start worrying about test scores or
things we have do or what people think
about us
but remind yourself that you are not
that
you are not defined by your test scores
you are not defined by your grades
and you are not defined by what people
think of you
you are pure consciousness
you associate yourself with your body
with your thoughts
but they're
part of you they aren't you
you're something deeper
and you're something far larger
think about how vast the universe is
not just vast in space but vast in time
that puts some of our problems in
perspective
a hundred years from now
a thousand years from now
will these problems really be that
significant
when you think about where you are on
this planet
part of the cosmos
are these issues really that significant
so i'll give you a few more moments to
just think about those ideas to just
think about the vastness of the universe
and what a privilege it is to be able to
participate in it to see the beauty of
it
and how small some of the things that we
often define ourselves by really are
and so now when you get a chance
gently with your eyes closed start to
feel and hear the room around you a
little bit get a little bit more in
touch with your body
and when you're ready open your eyes
and take these ideas take that stillness
with you through the rest of your day
and you should thank yourself for taking
the time out for doing this today
and i encourage you to make it a
practice some of you might be skeptical
what would a few minute meditation do
for me
but i can guarantee you if you do it day
in day out if you make a practice of it
do it regularly
over a few weeks a few months you're
going to notice some changes
you're going to see yourself be more
open to experience you're going to see
more beauty in more things
you're going to just have a positive
energy that people are going to want to
connect with that people are going to be
drawn to
and you'll also see that you're doing
better at some of those things we talked
about before because you're not stressed
about them anymore you're enjoying them
you're doing what you can
but you're not attached to the outcome
you do your best
wherever the chips fall
that's okay
if things don't turn out the way you
wanted that's okay you just accept where
things are
and then you decide what other actions
can you take
assemble your actions piece by piece
so that you can get to another outcome
but once again if the outcome is what
you want awesome if it isn't
accept it and move on from there
so i'll leave you in this meditation
thank you for joining and once again
thanks for taking time out for yourself
you